when President Trump visited with Queen
Elizabeth Friday he became the 12th
commander-in-chief
to meet Britain's longest-serving
monarch and Princess Elizabeth makes her
first appearance in the States
the Queen's first presidential encounter
actually took place 67 years earlier
when she was still a princess very great
pleasure for me as the president of the
United States to welcome you to in 1951
she and her husband Prince Philip hosted
harry s truman for a formal dinner at
the canadian embassy in washington Queen
Elizabeth's first visit with a president
after her coronation was with Dwight
Eisenhower two years later came her
first state dinner for a president
welcoming John F Kennedy and first lady
Jackie to a lavish affair at Buckingham
Palace that's also where Richard Nixon
met her majesty in 1969 but it was back
across the Atlantic in 1976 that
President Gerald Ford swept her Royal
Highness off her feet literally when the
two danced together during a White House
state dinner celebrating the American
bicentennial Ronald Reagan a particular
favorite of the Queen met her on four
different occasions the two who bonded
over their mutual love of horses
famously rode together in 1982 at
Windsor Castle Reagan described that as
one of the most fun moments of his
presidency the Reagan's it was a really
a really warm friendship I mean once
when the Queen was in California with
the royal yacht it was the Reagan's
wedding anniversary and she invited them
around for a for a special wedding
anniversary dinner and they all ended up
around the piano singing I mean those
are very special moments that don't
happen with a lot of world leaders
George HW Bush gave the British monarch
a taste of America's pastime inviting
the royal couple to catch a baseball
game in 1991 the Queen fit right in Bill
Clinton and George W Bush both met the
Queen several times during their
presidencies
but of course with all the protocol
involved Bo paws are bound to occur when
the Queen hosted Jimmy Carter for a
state dinner at Buckingham Palace the
39th president raised eyebrows when
instead of a bow he kissed the Queen
Mother right on the lips to Her Majesty
the Queen to the vitality of the special
relationship and toast to the Queen
President Obama's eggs right on talking
to this wasn't after the band had
started playing the British national
anthem
to the Queen
[Laughter]
yeah that's a faux pas what history only
president the only president not to meet
with the Queen during that time LBJ they
did correspond but they never actually
met kiss on the lips from Carter